hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
crispr based transcriptional activation
tools for silent jeans and filamentous
fungi i am marie stone of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrites and brought to
you by genscript to learn more visit
genscript.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
laszlo mojic post-doctoral researcher
university of groningen laden university
laszlo you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the introduction
hello everyone and welcome to my
presentation
um about crispr based transcriptional
activation tools for silent genes in
filamentous fungi
my name is lazlo mojic i am a
postdoctoral researcher at the
university of leiden
and
during this presentation i'm going to
talk about my work that i did as a phd
student at the university of groningen
in the department of uh arnold reason
as a table of content through the
presentation i would like to talk about
the importance of filamentous function
secondary metabolites that are produced
by fungi
i would like to introduce our new fungal
toolkit for modular cloning synthetic
biology tools for filamentous fungi
and
synthetic tools that we use to create
with these
with this toolkit for synthetic
transcriptional factors and as well as
as a title in the presentation crispr
eight based transcriptional activation
tools and we will close with a summary
and
questions
answering questions
but in the importance of filament to
spongy um if you want to pick
industrially relevant members of
sanji we can think about aspergillus
trichoderma penicillium and yesterday of
species
these species are known about their
organic acid production
as well as proteins and enzymes
and next to that secondary metabolites
which are not part of the primary
metabolism and produced
to provide other benefits for the fungi
are secondary metabolized which are
natural products
which can vary in structure and function
and contain
toxins alkaloids
pigments and even cellular force
during my work i wanted to uh
investigate this untapped reservoir of
secondary metabolites in filamentous
fungi
why do we think that's another reservoir
um
so far we have registered 120 000
species of fungi
from the predicted
size of 1.5 million
and every single species of
fungi is predicted to contain around 30
to 70 secondary metabolite producing
biosynthetic gene clusters
every single species
unfortunately most of the biosynthetic
gene clusters are often silent in
laboratory conditions and regulation is
also unknown of these clusters
by that we think that uh filamentous
fungi and finding uh
an uptick reservoir of potent chemicals
in the form of secondary metabolites
um so secondary metabolites come in
various forms and structures
and
their backbones is often produced by a
non-ribosomal peptide synthetases so
inner nfpss or polycatite synthesis
pks's
or
therapy synthesis
for example important members of the
nrps's are the penicillin the first real
antibiotic which is by penicillium
and
cyclosporine which is used now as an
immunosuppressant
as well as the mycotoxins uh
aflatoxin and journal tones which are
polycatite synthase
based
as well as the lobostatin which is a
cholesterol-lowering agent
um
how can we target biosynthetic gene
clusters in fibonacci responsible for
secondary metabolite production
so the backbone of these compounds that
it is produced commonly by nfps or pks
multi-domain mega enzymes
these domain protein domains are
conserved and can be
found by the
tools for example the anti-smash program
can
do that for you
and
it helps you in the identification of
biosynthetic gene clusters by comparing
your sequences with database respirators
for example the mit
where researchers
also share their findings and knowledge
about
biosynthetic chain clusters
but since these gene clusters often
surrendered by other genes for
example regulators transporters or
resistant genes and other tailoring
enzymes which further form the created
backbone
compound
and this can be also used
to identify
clusters
unfortunately the biosynthetic gene
clusters are as we mentioned often
silent in laboratory conditions and
there are many conventional ways how
these clusters can be transcriptionally
activated the promoter of the genes in
the gene cluster for example different
growth conditions or cultivation can
trigger the promoters of these genes
or heterologous expression moving out
the gene clusters and moving them into a
host
that we have familiar in the laboratory
or promoter exchange from the gene or
genes of interest by replacing the
original native promoter which is silent
with a new promoter with a strong
transcription rate which would result in
activation of these silent genes
there are also global regulators
present in the organisms
which are having a global effect on
transcriptional regulation so repression
of uh
elimination of a repressor or
overexpression and activator could
result in a global activation
as well as local transcriptional factors
which are responsible for regulating the
cluster
over expression a positive regulator
could result in
overexpression of the cluster or
eliminating a repressor could also
result in activation of the
transcriptional assignment by
intelligent
for secondary metabolize direction
um with the advent of crispr genome
editing
um the filamentous fungal fold it also
revolutionized genomic techniques
with the aid of a crispr based genome
editing we can now
precisely and easily perform gene
knockouts
marker-free or margin-based genome
accounts
and gene overexpression
through promoter replacement
or it's even possible to integrate
complete gene clusters and express them
heterogeneously in a new organism
on the figure which is presented here
repair from the marker 3
elimination of
pondants vacation domain of norebosoma
peptide synthase
and we only use the 106
base per homologous sequence marker-free
eliminating
these
unwanted
station domain
with synthetic biology tools
we can also
use
with combination of synthetic biology we
can use new tools for transcriptional
activation
since
using synthetic biology new tools can
emerge
for example
modular dna assembly tools can provide
rapid assembly of synthetic
transcription units
or whole
synthetic gene biocity gene clusters
or logical
gates can be also contracted for example
we can perform create on and on switches
for transcription activation
we can perform a domain swapping in
multi-domain mega enzymes using very
modular systems
or as i'm going to talk about in your
presentation we can use these tools for
creating synthetic transcription factors
um
fortunable expressions or crispr a or
crystal i for crispr based activation
and chamber interference for
transcriptional regulation
so first i would like to talk about the
synthetic transcription factors
so
transcription factors only
build up from a dna binding domain and
an activator domain the dna binding
domain it has the capacity of binding in
front of the gene of interest
through the promoter
and through the activator domain for
transcription activation or repressor
domain for transcriptional regression
can modulate the transcription from the
promoter of the gene of interest and by
attracting the rna polymerase to or
keeping it away for repression
and in synthetic transcription factors
we can create a hybrid of them so we can
combine the dna binding domain of the
choice with the modulator domain of that
we want to use in our whole system
so by creating
using synthetic biology tools we can
repurpose native biological systems
through modular assemblies and we can
construct various synthetic
transcription units
and
through synthetic
transcription factors combining dna
binding domains and regulator domains
we can modulate
the
expression of the gene of interest
and this could be
tuned
on gene of interest by expressing a
different amount of synthetic
transcription factors
or we can modulate the number of
upstream activating sequences where the
synthetic transcription factors can bind
in front of the promoter
of the gene of interest
or
we could modulate the
regulator domain for example the
strength of the activation domain can
also have an effect on the
transcription of the gene of interest
um to create a synthetic transcription
factor for panaceanium rubens we also um
aimed to use
a native fungal system repurposing it
for penicillium
and we used the
qf regulator from the queenic acid
metabolization biosynthetic gene cluster
and in the native system um the skew
clinic acid-based upstream activating
sequences urea are present in the
promoters of the queenic acid biophytic
gene cluster
and
without the qf positive regulator
there's no transcription coming out of
these things since the
the transcription activator is not
binding to the binding sequences
but when the transcription is present it
can bind and activate the gene cluster
and the quick acid metabolization gene
can be transcribed
but in native system also the repressor
is present and by that quenching the
activation and there's no activation
coming out of this bisected gene cluster
so to remodel this and it was already
done um through
mammalian cell lines and drosophila c
elegans and mosquito and zebrafish
we've repurposed it to penicillium
crystal genome for taking the activator
domain from this biosynthetic drain
cluster and the binding sequences
we wanted to create various synthetic
control devices using
different modules combined together
for example creating a synthetic
transcription factor combining the dna
binding domain of the previously
mentioned quinic acid
bicep gene cluster and combine it with
various activator domains
we wanted to test different amount of
quas binding sequences
since we decrease or increase the amount
of these binding sequences we should see
a scalable expression
through the gene of interest
these quas sequences were first with
core promoters or also called minimal
promoters
these promoters usually contain tata
boxes these are gc rich sequences and
they should be responsible for
recruiting the rna polymerase ii to the
promoter of the gene of interest
but these are not well defined in
filamentous fungi so we for penicillium
we took around 150 200 base per promoter
sequences upstream from the atg of
various genes
and they also tested promote core
promoters from after genus as well as
the harmony center easy and we
a feel them with the previous election
qaf sequences this is what we are going
to call core promoter to the
presentation
and
of course we plan to regulate the gene
of interest and this is for validating
created synthetic transcription factor
related
regulated uh readout we chose the ds red
as a red fluorescent protein
for validation of the system the
synthetic transcription factor as well
was also fused with the gfp so we were
able to visualize both the expression of
the synthetic transcription factor and
create a modular system where we always
aim to change one module
so when we started to work on this
project we created we started to create
we started to use a modular cloning for
modular assembly of various units
modular
cloning was originally
established in 2011
floor plans and then many labs started
to use modular cloning for modular
assembly
which is using a hierarchy car
theoretical assembly of a dna part
and rapidly
the user can create
transcription units consisting from
promoters and terminators
and various open reading frames or
protein fusions in between
and
based on this start we started to build
the first building blocks of our modular
synthetic biology toolkit which is now
um
got published at acs synthetic biology
where we deposited numerous promoters
terminators
and open reading frames for creating for
example synthetic transcription factors
as well as
crispr
based fusions for genome editing or
transcriptional regulation
using modular cloning we were able to
create
synthetic fusions
um
here
to introduce the hierarchical assembly
first
um the user has to create
dna parts that will be cloned into the
entry vectors of the system these are
usually called contain only one parts of
dna and this can be reshuffled in the
next step of the hierarchical assembly
these are called level one transcription
unit
and
we also provide that in this toolkit a
version where we can put this on an
armor vector ammo vectors secret armor
one sequences provide autonomous
replication in aspergillus and other
filamentous fungi so the user can
already reshuffle these uh dna parts
into a finger replicating vector
and in the next step of this
hierarchical assembly um a level two
final
multi gene um
vectors
numerous of the previously assembled
transcription units can be reshuffled
into one big vector
and
[Music]
this we also provided a vector
based where you can
replicate these multi-gene uh assemblies
into the momentous function
so
based on this assembly line we were able
to create numerous multi-gene
vectors which containing synthetic
transcription factors which were ready
to use to filamentous fungi
a schematic map of the synthetic
transcription vectors looped the
devices looped the
as you see it on the
presentation so we wanted to trust
numerous promoters
to drive
the simple transcription factor so we
were able to
module largely just exchange these
elements in the assembly line as well as
with mark with green you can see we
tested two different promoters as well
as two different activator domains in
the synthetic transcription factors in
red
you can see that it has the numerous
binding sequences for this synthetic
transcription factor
0 1 5 and 11 binding sequences as well
as i tested numerous chord promoters or
penicillium in front of the gene of
interest for
transcriptional regulation of the gene
of interest
and using fluorescent reporters
this
system was also easy to validate
um
[Music]
and
the reported system the created systems
were validated uh using
biolector micro
fermentations
and
from the fluorescent readout we were
able to evaluate the expression of the
gene of interest
and we saw that based on the chosen
chord or minimal promoter we had
different readouts so if we leave out
either the chord promoter or the binding
sequences from a synthetic
control device then we got a no
expression from the gene of interest
which is the dsred readout and depending
on the chosen quarter motor
we have different readout on the gene of
interest
as well as we also saw that the number
of binding sequences regulate um
expression on the gene of interest we
can see on the slide b
that
0
1
5 or a 5 reverse sequence or 11 binding
sequences
create an increased amount of expression
from the gene of interest
and on the slide c we can see a
comparison where we compared
two native genes from the penicillin uh
production
so driving pcb ab and pcbc the first two
genes of the penicillin biosynthetic
gene cluster
and
[Music]
we compared the expression of our best
working system and we were able to show
that transcription levels can create
comparable levels to this highly
transcribed
promoters
and
to show the usability of the system we
also integrated
the synthetic control devices into the
penicillin biosynthetic gene cluster so
as i mentioned penicillin biosynthetic
gene cluster that consists of three
genes a pcbab ecbc and pcb
pc a10da
and the integrated
binding sequences for the synthetic
transcription factor in front of
the core promoters of pcbc and pcb 80 as
well as mda
where we also integrated the synthetic
transcription factor cassettes itself
and we put this under the regulation of
the synthetic transcription factor
and we saw in every day where we use
five or eleven binding sequences for
deriving the first two genes we saw a
scalable expression from these genes as
well as uh since this resulted
us to realize that the pcb av corporate
is rather weak promoter we also build a
system where we use the food promoter
for driving pcb
and it also resulted that every time
when you compare 5 and 11 binding
sequences
uh it can
it and results in a scaled
expression
so as you can see uh synthetic
transcription factors this regulation
um
can result in a scaled
expression on the gene of interest
but unfortunately every uh gene has to
be engineered for this purpose
and
[Music]
twister-based transcriptional regulation
on the other hand could provide
transcriptional regulation without the
need for genome editing
for example if we don't have to
introduce crispr but in
few words
the crispr
[Music]
nuclei is originally guided with a
single guide running the gene of
interest but it can
create a
dna bracket
which can be repaired by various ways
if you use
nuclease that cast 9 or that ks9
this cas9 protein doesn't have a nucleus
activity and by that it still can be
guided by using a single guys running to
the locus of interest
but it uh does not cut the dna anymore
and if we are talking about and if we
fuse a regulator domain to this
guidable protein we can also create a
synthetic transcription factor that we
could create a guide to the promoter of
the gene of interest
and
by
deploying a regulator protein to these
segments and we could create a
regulation transcription regulation on
demand
and we chose a photorescription
activation
the dpr
preparation activator domain which shown
to be
functional in numerous species already
and we established it for penicillium
[Music]
and
in case the gene of interest
would be a transcriptional regulator a
positive transcriptional regulator
biosynthetic gene cluster we would also
expect that activation of the regulator
could also weighten up a whole
biosynthetic gene cluster
so we built a vector using the synthetic
modular toolkit that we established we
created a vector where we can
[Music]
which consist two different uh fungal uh
selection markers as well as it's
expressing uh that class nine uh by
perfusion and it has a single guide dna
plug and play uh module where we were
able to
plug in the single guide rna which
contains the target sequence that we
want to
target with this protein
and we were able to rapidly clone
uh and
deliver it to
penicillium which was the host for a
readout
and
as a proof of principle we chose the
previously established a core promoter
system without any binding sequences
because
if for example
one of our very big promoter the
promoter pandia core promoter
um
should be a very big the activatable
promoter but with still the capability
of
being as a functional promoter
and without binding sequences for the
synthetic transcription factor system
this promoter should not expense express
detectable amount of red force and
proteins
and
through the activation
with a crispr a based transcriptional
regulation
we should be able to activate this
promoter which still has functional
element as being a promoter and we
should see a red fluorescent signal
activated so to finance and microscopy
we investigated uh
strains
which contained which were targeting six
different
landing sites
in the promoter of this
motor nda it's nice to notice that we
are talking about an only 200 base per
long promoter
where um 30 percent of it is the
established uh untranslated region of
the
rna the transcript
and we are targeting in front of this
sequence with six different
targeting signals
targeting sequences for crispr a
and
from six different targets in four cases
we were able to detect um
percent signal
so
compared to the native system where
river did not have a single guide rna
targeting
the ds red
so
we after we established a fluorescent
reporter readout in the system shown to
be successful to activate
a silent promoter
an artificial silent promoter
we took a
native
transcriptionally silent biosynthetic
gene cluster for secondary metabolites
in penicillium rubens or previously the
visual specimen crystal genome
and we chose the macroporine
antimicrobial biosynthetic gene cluster
which homologue was identified in
tunisian terrestre
but this cluster seems to be
transcriptionally silent in penicillin
rubens in our cultivation conditions
and
we targeted the promoter of the putative
transcriptional regulator of this
biosynthetic gene cluster
and we also engineered a strain the
repair from promoter replacement
next to the
crispr a plasmid based transcriptional
activation
here the promoter is uh the whole
promoter is the five around 550 base per
long promoter
and we planned to and it targeted around
every 50 base per
one single guide rna landing site for
that case nine wiper
on both strands of the promoter
and after transforming these
constructs into filamentous fungi on
solid and later on liquid media we
performed readout
to identify macroporium-related
compounds
and in two cases out of the 20 different
targets we were able to identify
macroporine related compounds through
lcms
we also realized a dark pigmentation
both with the promoter engineering and
as well as one of the
whisper based activator uh strains
and it is interesting to notice here
that
from these 20 sequences as we can see
that some of them are very far from the
putative transcription start site
uh 12 out of 20 would fall into the
formally accepted targeting window of
good targets for
crispr activation
and unfortunately only two of these uh
single-gallon spacers were able to
activate uh through crystal activation
the gene of interest
and after validating uh on solid agar um
by macrocuring related compounds we also
performed liquid cultures where we
performed qpcr on the genes of the gene
cluster we investigated the regulator
the mock a which is the first gene of
the biosynthetic gene cluster as well as
mark j which is the last gene of the
biosynthetic gene cluster and we show
realized activation through the
biosynthetic gene cluster as well as the
targeted regulator as well as the
biosensory gene cluster which is
regulated by the regulator
as a summary i would like to summarize
that filamentous fungi is a rich
reservoir and secondary mat in the form
of secondary metabolite biosynthetic
gene clusters
for useful natural products
unfortunately most of the biosynthetic
gene clusters are transcriptionally
silent in laboratory conditions and new
synthetic biology tools are needed and
required for rapid and efficient
interrogation of these gene clusters
for example modular cloning toolkits can
speed up the steps of synthetic biology
for
assembling new synthetic transcription
units
for example synthetic transcription
factors can be created for activating
all biosynthetic gene clusters
but unfortunately using uh such
synthetic transcription factors often
genome editing is needed uh although
this could provide a scalable
transcription which can be scaled joined
by gene
but on the other hand using crispr based
transcription regulators for crispr a
for activation or crispr eye for
transcriptional reproduction this could
provide a genum editing free
transcriptional regulating system
but so far unfortunately empirical
testing of these single galleries is
needed since there's no uh real
trouble prediction how can such
activator
single bedroom be designed
i would like to close my presentation to
say thank you to the people who being
part of this project
of course my p.i are not reasoned and my
co-supervisors rule bollenberg and
tiffany guard
and as well as
people who um
ricardo niels and carsten
thank you for your attention and
i am happy to answer and discuss
questions
thank you laszlo for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for so let's get started
our first question is
if active sgrnas vary by the targeted
promoter in the crispr activation
approach
how could we ensure transcriptional
activation
um
yes it's a good question of course
um
the informatic tools can help you to
predict a good target for crispr a
binding
and it's a general
rule that in front of the transcription
status
it's a
fair spot for mining for transcriptional
positive regulators
and we want to achieve transcriptional
repression
going further down in this transcription
site we can create a repression effect
but next to that unfortunately there are
no and of course taking into account
the effect but next to that only
empirical testing is possible
to ensure that we chose a working single
guided rna the other option that we
could do is multiplexing so delivering
multiple single guide rnas at the same
time on the same vector for example and
that would increase the chances that our
cycle single guiding is actually working
for the selected promoter of the gene of
interest
great thank you
next question
what other transcriptional regulation
domain fusions would be interesting to
test in crispr fusions
um of course
foreign organisms various
domain fusions been already been tested
any methylation is possible for
interesting would be
[Music]
histone diacetylase then histone
acetylation
that could create a global
for example acetylated channel that was
created a locally lucenta chromatin that
could also contribute for
transcriptional activation locally for a
gene or a whole gene cluster of the
interest
according to my opinion
great thank you
next question
could we
could we use tools for high throughput
transcriptional activation
of transcriptionally silent biosynthetic
gene clusters
well it is possible to bring to high
throughput fungal transformation so
using automated machines you could
create a library of various vectors we
are talking about maybe one single uh
single quadrant or even multiple single
guidelines deployed on one vector and
deployed into the organism
and
that could bring us to the level where
we just feed the dna with these
activators and then we could interrogate
these genes or whole chain clusters in a
more rapid manner combined with crispr a
technology
of course we're talking about the
synthetic transcription factors where we
have to engineer the genome that's can
be a more tedious
way to do so and that can be also
brought to
automated
levels
but
yeah the user has to decide on which
approach to take
thank you
next question
what does the fluorescent reporters help
to do
so
we use fluorescent reporters
to
activate
to validate our
systems and for the synthetic
transcription factors we labeled with
gst the synthetic transcription factors
to monitor the presence and expression
of the synthetic transcription of
effects
and we used ds red red fluorescent
proteins
for validating the readout from the gene
of interest
so
when we evaluated the readout of the
system we were able to detect the
produced ds red
and we were able to normalize with the
produced
synthetic transcription factor because
it was labeled with gfp so the
normal
the all the data were normalized might
have produced
um
transcription factor in the cell
thanks to biomass
thank
you and uh of course it will be a spread
readout from the same system for the
crisp array uh transcription factor of
activator so in that case
this is the same uh
silent synthetic promoter that should
have been silent without activator and
with activation you manage to see the
yes red readout
that's what we use there
uh jordan reporters for
great thank you
next question
um
do you think it would be possible to
assemble the system in vitro and later
deliver it into a broader range of
target organisms
for instance by synthesizing
ready-to-use ribonucleoparticles
i think that's a great idea and we also
uh when we are troubleshooting that of
the system we also considered
that option
but we actually disregarded
that solution since
fungal transformation and later
cultivation is a rather
time consuming process
so that would mean that the activator
protein has to be present at the moment
of transformation and meanwhile you get
to the state when you are having your
readout of
your
transfection activation
and i'm afraid that uh rnp method would
not be present or its effect would not
be present
as long to be able to have a proper
readout
of course it's possible now that
for example you transform with guarantee
your protoplast and you try to have your
readout as soon as possible after the
moment of transformation
but
i think it's
[Music]
providing less
stable delivery of the creeper
activators
thank you
it looks like we have time for one more
question
how concerned are you about off target
activation
while we didn't
really look into off-target effects of
course we selected all our single
grinder any spacers
manually created for avoiding
all targets binding
but if that would be the case
for example
we can create off-target activation of
lethal genes in a very unfortunate case
then you would probably not get colonies
and
[Music]
we could also create a repressor if the
crispr activator binds on places where
it should not and again in little places
we should not get on it but we
didn't really uh take it into account
uh undesired of target uh
bindings with this system
with the efficiency that we saw that
we had to get uh
the multiple single gathering is to
receive activation
i think it's also
it's an off-target binding where you're
single is not
match it's also highly unlikely that you
would reproduce after getting activation
well thank you vaslo do you have any
final comments for the audience
um
well
into biology
speeding up molecular biology and
genetic engineering so
let's keep making the
molecular machine
great
well thank you again laszlo for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor jen script for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed
until next time goodbye